he's my best friend Catherine zeta-jones
and Michael Douglas's son Dylan is all
grown up the 49 year old actresses 18
year old son was by her side along with
husband Michael for a special ceremony
on Wednesday in Wales where her home
town was honoring her with the honorary
Freedom of the City and County of
Swansea Catherine looked elegant in a
hot pink off-the-shoulder sheath dress
while Michael wore a gray suit in maroon
tie we're very dumb right now not
anymore it seems Dylan proudly supported
his mama looking dapper and grown up in
a black suit gray tie and white
button-down I love it back in November
Catherine opened up to ET about how
lucky she feels to have such grounded
kids they're kind of been removed from
the crazy world of Hollywood or even the
crazy world of Manhattan you know the
teenagers of here in Manhattan it's very
there's a maturity that comes too quick
I think and so we've kind of shielded
them away but they're incredibly mature
for their tender years you know they
they get it and that's something that I
just I think I just got lucky
[Music]